[Music]
you know what this really is the summer
of fierce fighting females and Charlize
is just that in her new movie atomic
blonde and guess what only we can take
you behind the scene for myself as a
woman to you know take part in a film
and not play somebody that has to let
everybody or an audience know every five
minutes then she has boobs that's really
great
Charlize kicks major butt in her new
movie atomic blonde and when it comes to
how female action heroes operate she's
breaking the rules her character doesn't
have a traditional love interest and
instead of playing it pretty after a
fight scene you'll see her battered and
bruised it was very clear the way I was
gonna fight how a woman would really be
able to fight in the great every bone in
her fist how a woman fights is pretty
fierce when you see Charlize going at it
stunt coordinators had planned to take
it easy on her that was until they saw
what she could do
she's just as good as a man you can take
this story and you can flip it and it
works exactly the same way and that
strength is something that I'm really
proud of Charlie spent four hours a day
for two and a half months doing martial
arts drills to prepare for her role as
an international spy it earned her a
twisted knee bruised ribs and cracked
teeth stunt guys took so many hits I had
to buy a lot of alcohol to be forgiven
but there were no injuries there were
absolutely nothing or so they told me so
I don't know maybe they went home and
cried and guess what I am headed to
Berlin because next week
Charley's and I are going to co-host the
show together so cool me and wait for it
yeah music I know I'm yeah I'm giving
you time
[Music]
you